bt je vois amis pendant 10 ans directeur
de la rédaction de ça se discute bravo
c'est un carton ouais est-ce que vous
allez rencontrer jean luc delarue
justement dans le cadre du travail vous
êtes mes amis bien avant et c'est lui
qui vous a demandé de venir travailler
que lui j'ai rencontré jean luc en
1987 c'est pas hier non à l'époque
j'étais président des restos du coeur et
il m'avait interviewé europe 1 de ce que
lui commencé europe 1 et voilà on a eu
une sorte de coup de foudre amical moi
je me sentais un peu orphelins parce que
coluche venait de mourir
un an plus tôt et on a eu un coup de
foudre amical et puis voilà ça a duré
dix ans dix ans plus souvent à
transféreront la comptine glace voir
quoi d'accord d'abord c'est une amie des
siens de ses vécus sont 97 18 18 18
d'accord voilà passé de une deux images
pour peut-être des
bassidjis étaient les deuxièmes parties
de soirée de france 2 mardi la ricoh dit
c'est ça oui et puis à cheval y avait
une thématique était très préparé là on
a deux extraits la mâle à la femme
autoritaire c'est ce qui marque un petit
peu qu après les jeunes amoureux c'était
très mignon
il a attendu
jeudi
car j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je me ferais
bouffer tout seul bah ouais tu sais fort
bien que c'est moi tous les sites elle
me dit celui
tous les week-ends olivier joue au
football avec ses ennemis sa femme est
muriel l'accompagnent pour l'encourager
ce parti n'est pas finie à ses
souffrances olivier qui se tait qui
s'écrase c'est le cas de le dire et de
faire
alors comme ça vous verrez c'est très
mignon il a comme lui des enfants que
l'eepad jeunes amoureux regarder ouais
le principal c'est d'être amoureux vous
êtes amoureux tous les deux oui
tu as dit que tu es sûr où tu es pas sur
olivia
[Musique]
c'est sûr ça veut dire quoi être
amoureux pour vous
ça fait plus de trois en tout cas que
vous êtes amoureux l'un de l'autre qu
est-ce qu olivia de plus ou de mieux
guillaume que les autres filles que tu
connais qu'est ce qui te plaît chaudière
si jamais elle nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
si notre étoile est bien à sa maison
olivia te plaît pourquoi
pourquoi te plaît
parce qu'elle me trouve très beau
[Applaudissements]
nathalie exclusive de de son papa il
avait créé un style alors loriette
adhérents convoyer comme ça c'est un
style ça c'est un truc qui explique un
peu aux américains d'avoir comme ça la
tablette tout ça il avait créé un
véritablement un ski c'est à dire que
c'était un truc qu'il avait piqué aux
américains mais surtout notre qu'utile
parce que le nombre de deux témoins qui
avaient dans l'émission faisait que
toute manière il te plaît d'avoir son
conducteur sous les yeux est ce que
c'était vraiment un bosseur ah oui
jean-luc c'était un hyper hyper bosseur
ouais d'accord alors justement on en
parlait moi je disais à partir de 94,10
va commencer à toucher beaucoup d'argent
est ce que c'est à ce moment là on dit
tous les maux aujourd'hui à que là
qu'arrive l'alcool la drogue les les
faits à ce moment-là il pète les plombs
non ça n'arrive pas à ce moment-là ça à
ce moment là effectivement il se passe
quelque chose parce que tout d'un coup
on va lui donner un ton d'or pour entrer
sur le service public et donc effectué
mon tout change d'échelle et forcément
et il commence à avoir des désirs enfin
voila il commençait à la terre à la tête
d'un petit empire ouais donc forcément
ça enfle la tête de n'importe qui mais
elles ne l'ont taguée chez caudalie
matin venu beaucoup mais qui passait
autour de moi je les connais
quelques-uns avaient mais surtout sur
quelqu'un qui a quand même une
psychanalyste particulière de nos amours
de lui-même il ya c'est un personnage
psychotique compliqué jean luc delarue
en baisse un personnage éminemment
contradictoires en même temps ces
comètes avec un talent fantastique
capacité à enregistrer de l'info une
éponge en même temps un mec qui a été lu
et dans des valeurs on va dire de
partage des valeurs de même dur des
valeurs c'est comme ça qu'il est léger
de gauche employons de mômes et il va se
retrouver un peu en contradiction avec
tout ça c'est à dire je me souviens en
97 il va voter pour la gauche en disant
[ __ ] que je fais un vote contre mon
pognon travailler il commence à vivre
mais sans doute il donc animatrice sur
tf1 qu' arrêter maintenant mais je pense
qu'il me faudra pas le dire parce que -
l'a pas vécue elle travaille avec lui
amusé quand on aller dîner chez lui tout
d'un coup je lisais maintenant sandrine
battant ce qui va se passer maintenant
je veux pas que tu vois et je me disais
pour nous téléspectateurs on avait le
garçon qui avait là les matches ici qu
était le gendre idéal qui fumait pas
qu'ils buvaient pas qui rien et quand il
servait cette porte derrière on l'a su
plus tard c'était des litres d'alcool
c'était des cigarettes c'était de la
cocaïne c'était oui mais seuls donc oui
mais puis c'est tout mais là aussi tu
dis tout mon travail commence comment
comment ce qui m'a pas comment est ce
qu'on a pu à ce point c'est samedi les
deux villes parce que c'est très
compliqué avec jean-luc devant quand le
séisme qu'a eu sur le plan d'argent en
oublie qu'on leur a donné des sommes
qu'ils n'osaient même pas demandé non
seulement ça fait sa part au cerveau
immédiatement ensuite son problème sap a
été la cocaïne et l'alcool et tout ça a
été sa recherche désespérée d'un père de
substitution
pardon hein on est tous là dessus c'est
et claude berri c'était françois meyer
garde des gens qui ne le méritait pas
honnêtement et puis après ça a été avant
les médicaments il provoque chez moi la
cocaïne et l'alcool que les médicaments
départ c'est dans la cité l'euro idole
pour s'endormir et prenaient des médocs
pour se réveiller il prenait 2 mai
doivent pour tenu parce que c'était un
ambitieux chronique accord et qu'ils
bossaient tellement moi je me souviens
d'une nuit et créer un décor pour
l'émission du lendemain eh ben c'est un
décor de faux livres il est bien mais
non mais moi je veux des vrais libre il
a fallu y tomber de 300 livres dans la
nuit qui était tellement perfectionniste
et je vous garantis moi qui ai jamais
pris un joint de ma vie il pouvait avoir
des rapports normaux tout en ayant une
vie compliquée avec des gens qui étaient
normaux ce qui est désespérément monclar
se remettre dans ce bouquin écrit quand
même eu alors une dernière réunion mais
il en réunion en force télévision donc
il avec les ponts de france télévisions
comme maria et et pardon attendre c'est
parce qu'il raconte et raconte que oui
ils doivent tourner à ça se discute ça
discute tous le public est là tout le
monde attend et on attend l'animateur et
ils attendent une demi heure trois
quarts d'heure une heure une heure rien
et tout d'un coup quelqu'un pour le
téléphone et la pelle sur son portable
et il entend je suis caché je suis caché
dans un placard
qu'est ce que tu fais quelque chose dans
le placard jean-luc on t'attend ce
plateau faut pas que mon fils me
trouveront fait un cache cache
là on se rend compte qu'on a atteint des
niveaux oui il est plus sur terre sur la
fin on a atteint des niveaux de métro
qui fait ça là on est à la fin là on est
à la fin d'un processus maladif qui
effectivement qui peut toucher plein de
gens mais là qu'il a touché lui va vous
l'avez quittée vous notamment non c'est
pas pour ça moi je vais quitter parce
que on était on s'est connus je vous dis
on était très amis on part en vacances
ensemble etc et puis ont partagé
ensemble certain nombre de vidéos quand
on a créé ça discute notre pari c'était
simple c'était de dire les gens qui sont
pas connus ou autant de choses
intelligentes à dire que les gens qui
sont très connus et qui la ramène donc
au départ c'est ça la volonté de faire
ça se discute alors j'ai visualisé ou
deux j'ai une question paraît dans leurs
marques à bréhal et après donc quand ça
va se séparer quand je me rends compte
qu'à ce moment-là son objectif dans pire
parce que c'était un vrai c'était un
rêve il voulait avoir un immeuble à son
nom qu'à un moment donné ça va les
bouffer et moi je me rends compte qu'on
est de plus en plus éloignés qu'on
n'arrive plus à se dire des trucs et il
va se passer un événement qui pour moi
est majeur c'est la mort de mon père
mais c'est un truc et il me dit bien sûr
parce qu'ils connaissaient mes parents
je vais me à l'enterrement de ton père
et il vient pas il vient pas il me dit
le lendemain je me suis pas réveillé
j'ai fait la fête hélas oui bien sûr et
là j'en ai pas voulu mais pour moi il y
avait un truc cas c'est que ça a l'air
con mais c'est ça alors alors entre l'as
tu as fait d'aider des mines des dîners
avec toi tout ça bien sûr avec pascal
bataille aussi et jean-luc eu à chaque
fois c'était surréaliste exactement ce
qu'on décrit certains on arrivé à 8h
réaliser un truc des horaires 8h ses
huit heures il était déjà à table avec
jacques debout une bouteille de vin
généralement et il était d'amener un
dernier dîner que j'ai fait avec lui il
était à côté de moi parce qu'elle est en
face et son dg était en face de jean luc
et ils buvaient des coupes de vin rouge
au genre papa du rosé avec des glaçons
comme ça on les descendants et dédiant
un demi litre en une en quelques gorgées
voilà et il en prenait un deuxième et un
troisième ce que je leur mets toutes les
personnes qui témoignent qui ont
travaillé avec lui qu'ils ont et qui ont
fait partie de son cercle proche disent
toutes qu'elles ne l'ont jamais vu
prendre de drogue que c'était vraiment
une honte est ce que c'est cette
sélection je voulais vous poser est ce
que vous l'avez vu
également être dépendant de quoi que ce
soit oui que c'était un sujet tabou non
c'est faux j'ai vu ça d'une part sa vie
et même je vais même vous dire il
m'arrivait d'en prendre avec lui
d'accord je veux dire c'est un truc
qu'on faisait entre nous entre copains
et c'est la chance intacte café oui
madame
il après si vous voulez n'y a pas de
face cachée de jean launay quai comme
c'est un homme qui a plein de facettes
mais à face cachée d'accord lui même à
chaque fois
juste avant justement autodestructeur
non c'est ça une sorte de moi je jouais
digne de gens me j'ai inscrit 10 et je
me sais quoi dans ce coup de blues la
sculpture grecque de la rue c'est vrai
pour la drogue c'était de notoriété
commune c'est vrai que c'était voilà
c'était une dépendance et ça
malheureusement contrecarrer certains de
ses projets professionnels système pour
l'obi-1 producteur de génie un animateur
de la guerre plus absolument vraiment
qu'ils se sentaient qu'avec qui sentait
le lundi 8 ans et c'était au moment de
l'explosion du phénomène miss france en
france il a eu l'idée de créer de miss
afrique et donc du coup il est parti au
sénégal augmenterait le président du
sénégal de l'époque voilà pour organiser
une mission de toute l'afrique est
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
pour lui il avait décidé de il voulait
pas arriver au sénégal à dakar sans
qu'ils aient de drogue sur place et donc
du coup il a envoyé quelqu'un de son
équipe de trois jours avant pour qu'ils
puissent acheter de la drogue mais on
retrouve dès son arrivée à l'hôtel
malheureusement la personne qui
l'envoyaient n'était pas kenya qui
consommaient quelqu'un qui s'y
connaissait et karité n'importe quoi en
fait et du coup franc il arrivé au
sénégal et au à dakar il a commencé à
plaindre hug qui n'était pas de la
cocaïne qui est une drogue beaucoup plus
forte il n' y voit le président du
sénégal il commence entretient son
assistant qui comprenait aussi comment
savoir de la bave qui sort et devient
blanc vert jean luc delarue site très
très mal l'assistant tombe dans les
pommes mais il faut faire venir les
services d'urgence et nous avons le truc
mais le président voit ça il est affolé
par l'image ou la mauvaise image que ça
peut donner il prend tout le monde prend
des affaires l'hôtel retour en avion et
retour à paris l'élection miss après
miss afrique italie c'est dans ce que tu
me disais comment se fait-il on parle on
parle de la part de rien à voir on parle
d'aidé ppda des mythes ou des machins
tout le monde ça met la ps1 et tout ça
tout le monde savait effectivement
france télévisions j'imagine les
dirigeants savaient et assure que ce
gala fig consona
les dirigeants de france télévisions
pour qui j'avais beaucoup de tendresse
me souviendrai toujours de voeux de
nouvel an chez red bull mais jean-louis
je commençais à perdre vraiment les
pédales là tout en étant moi je mets
toujours été attaché jusqu'au bout
c'était un homme moi je les adore mais
je l'adorent irréversiblement mais je
leur ai dit vous ne vous rendez pas
compte comme vous l'exposez il est
encore en direct à ce moment là et il
allait présenter les fameux globe de
cristal je leur ai dit mais il va faire
les globes de cristal en direct mais il
n'est pas en état et les pongistes
bientôt sa poésie n'est pas en état et
ils m'ont dit qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'on va j'ai dit mais route sept
présentés par quelqu'un dans ce n'est
pas le seul animateur un petit jeune
j'ai drucker ils m'ont dit on va
regarder résultat il a présenté des
glaces mais de mode c'est un bon club ça
a été un désastre ont animé en ré
équilibrer tout ça on peut aussi quand
même rappeler que c'était quelqu'un qui
avait un discours intéressante
paradoxalement parce que quand il s'est
fait choper par la police quand on a
chopé laisse bien sûr et trouvé des
stupéfiants chez lui après il a démarré
ce qu'il a appelé une cure de
sensibilisation il ya deux réponses un
tour de france en camping-car pour aller
parler dans les lycées 2h écrivait sans
omettre tous les aspects les plus
sombres des journées et des nuits qui
pouvait passer et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'importance nous n'allons
pas baisser
les marges totalement sincère et s
calcul des réserves quand
il était saturé de tellement de choses
que quand il sait ce vrai brutalement
mais ça a été pour l'organisme a été un
choc énorme une sorte de septicémie et
il a conduit lui même le 24 11 mille
kilomètres dans la france entière il a
fait ça comme tout le reste à son à fond
à fond de rédemption un peu plus direct
plus calmes et du coup ils avaient faire
décombres d'un elie saab il ya des gens
qui venaient se confier à lui et ça a
été une charge émotionnelle très très
lourd beaucoup trop lourde et c'est vrai
qu'on a pas on à l'interview exclusive
de son père mais c'est tellement
intéressant qu'on va passer la semaine
prochaine parce que si on va être en
cours avec les gens de l'amour est dans
le pré et c'est dommage de qu'on va
refaire un dossier aussi et la semaine
prochaine quelques veut dire un dernier
mois peut-être sur jean luc delarue
voilà ça fait dix ans je sais que c'est
un mec que j'ai beaucoup aimé oui moi
aussi
générosité vous
ils organisaient des soirées
complètement dingue la soirée rose à
l'olympia il ou elle olympia louey des
hôtels et privatiser des hôtels à disney
pour ses équipes c'était quelqu'un qui
paradoxalement même s'ils étaient
vraiment durs dans le travail était
d'une générosité extraordinaire boom
accord avec vous la question de l'avoir
quittée non non parce que au moment où
je quittais je sentais que moi je
commençais à être très dansant dans
lorsque je voulais être son délire mais
ça n'est pas arrivé parce que moi même
je me suis je me sentais me perdre parce
que ça on se perd dans ce revirement et
d'épée
la zone soit membre de l'amicale ont
quitté pour une raison à michael arrêts
et les rangers une raison aux
allégations profité non
que sinon on allait plus de potes quoi
pas là est ce que l'on se perd des gens
me sens tellement de gens qui nous ont
enfoncés carmes en profiter mais bien
sûr bien sûr qui est sûr c'est quand on
a contacté tous les gens de réservoir
prod pour venir témoigner sur scène ma
réaction aucun n'a voulu venir et tous
nous disent y en a même un qui m'a dit
on ne viendra pas parce qu'on tient à
notre place et qu'on n'a pas envie de
témoigner aux lettres vous parlez là
maintenant maintenant aujourd'hui sache
que je je je je vois les gens si peur de
cendres et ya une omerta pelé parce que
vous n'avez pas remarqué que les gens
ont souvent beaucoup peur de claude
sujet de beaucoup de sujets mais
absolument à la peur c'est quand même un
truc assez largement répandue à tout le
monde a peur pour sa place on savait ce
qu'on appelle le parapluie aux planques
c'est commerci